[Music]
[Applause]
you know faker and you know his story
the greatest player to ever touch League
of Legends exploded onto the sea by the
end of his first year of pro play he was
a world champion who was the face of his
game the next generation they called him
the unkillable demon king
they called him God
Baker built the game's greatest dynasty
he faced down every Challenger and he
defeated all but at Worlds 2017 that all
came crashing down
[Music]
[Applause]
finger
the unkillable demon king had died the
inevitable became the inadequate but he
wasn't done this is the story of how
league's greatest player tasted defeat
sunk to his lowest point and came
roaring back
[Music]
this is faker and his story isn't over
yet
[Music]
after three consecutive World Finals SKT
were finally not the best team in the
world so now the question was could
faker find a way to become the game's
most dominant player yet a game to do it
SKT would have to assemble a new roster
welcome to the 2018 lck spring rookie
top tall and rookie jungler blossom
stepped into the roster that effort
who'd been a substitute support in 2017
joined the starting lineup and it didn't
take long to see that the experiment
wasn't going to work not only break the
losing streak they go to game 3 versus
SK Telecom t1 and then defeat them in a
match for the first time since they've
joined the lck it's a 2-1 it's a
different story the first meeting in
this particular season for the abrecan
freaks and SKT but the same result in
the end after a one-in-five start in the
spring season blossom got to start in
the jungle over blank and SKT managed to
climb to a spot that was far from
dominant but put them in the playoffs
but their longtime telecom rivals kt
rolster didn't recognize the SKT they
faced in the quarterfinals fakers team
was eliminated 31 and SKT would not
attend msi for the first time since the
tournament was created in 2015 it was
one of the lowest points of fakers
career and as his star waned the
international league scene was starting
to shift
[Music]
[Applause]
but it got even worse the summer saw SKT
failed to qualify for the playoffs and
faker even saw some time in the bench as
period played in some important
victories for the team coaches have
entered the booth and guys you're
expecting Frankie to come back it looks
like he's not gonna be there that was
period on your screen the bid
flabbergasted don't see the posture of
the mid lane of cell faker joining the
squad been period is who they're going
to choose when it all comes down to this
game number three in the end this roster
at this time just could do are gonna be
making it to the friday matchup up
against Griffin it was close here in
five games but 10t they're able to pull
it out everyone at the Nexen arena and
you in the chat were there when the
dream died for SK Telecom
tu on the run that saw them hit three
consecutive world finals does and today
after a heartbreaking loss to Genji in
the gauntlet Baker failed to qualify for
Worlds he'd have to sit out the game's
biggest event for the first time since
2014
in a year faker had gone from a
heartbreaking second place at Worlds two
missing worlds completely in a lot of
ways it mirrored 2014 faker missed out
on another tournament hosted on home
soil
changes you
and the truffle 2018 season changed
fakers approach to the scene he stopped
reading everything his fans posted about
him on social media he began to fear
that the negative things they said might
come true and for faker time marched on
at the end of 2018 he was the oldest
starting mid laner in the lck 2014 faker
feeling the sting of missing worlds
threw himself into the game but in 2018
after being eliminated in the gauntlet
he took a break he admitted he was
feeling anxious and that he couldn't
confront the feeling without resting and
considering it and while he said he
didn't defeat it completely he argued
that he could turn it toward the future
as motivation 2014 faker was intense and
irrepressible 2018 faker was vulnerable
but with the kind of confidence that
comes from feeling the pain of failure
and knowing that it can't be allowed to
define your present what was in front of
faker for 2019 was a team filled with
some of the biggest names in League of
Legends
[Music]
the rule and I'm throwing time over 20
times and i amö boys weren't properly
baker was officially made team captain
after resigning with SKT he almost
undoubtedly received offers from all
over the world
but he chose to remain in his home
region but his region was burning Korea
had their worst showing ever at Worlds
2018 failing to even make the
semi-finals
get a dear old girl has fallen and
effect this gaming will do
the fakir wanted his country to reclaim
the throne
it seemed he would have to do it himself
by the time the 2019 season kicked off
Baker was clearly part of a contending
team they spent most of spring in second
place behind a nearly unbeatable Griffin
roster but playoff SKT is always a force
and they swept both their semi-final
match against King zone and the finals
against Griffin
Griffen of today red opal first round
robin Baker had earned another lck title
his seventh
but despite the team strong showing he
took a moment to apologize to his former
teammates from 2018 for the team's
previous poor performance okay
emotional even in victory Baker was
already looking ahead to msi you're
gonna win the msi - i'm gonna win the
world the midseason Invitational would
be a chance for faker to show the spring
run was more than a domestic title it
could be the reamer gence of a global
contender and korea previously so used
to winning on the world stage hadn't
taken a single event since world's 2017
they desperately wanted an international
victory and even as korea had fallen
other regions rose to take their place
china seemed poised to assume the throne
but Europe and even North America could
no longer be ignored I think the shape
of international League of Legends
changed a lot by the time we were
heading into MSI 2019 Korea four years
had been this unassailable giant right
but by that point I think people had
realized that wasn't the case they
really fell down at Worlds 2018 and
other regions had started to emerge as
real threats on the international stage
obviously China were the winners of
Worlds 2018 but Europe and even North
America were starting to produce some
teams that the international
you really had to take seriously in the
group stage SKT put up a solid 7 and 3
record but worryingly 2 of those losses
came against g2 eSports the European
organization with a flair for
unpredictable strategies
[Applause]
the other came against Invictus gaming
China's representative at the tournament
and the 2018 world champions eighties
road to an MSI wind may have looked
difficult but it certainly didn't seem
implausible their first-round opponent
though was the one they found the most
difficult in groups maybe but a spicy
game ahead
I mean Taipei is Bob big we're bubbling
we're ready to jump up and down like
Kobe was yesterday and which way it goes
is so up in the air we had a moment in
time yesterday another one is gonna be
made today and sake it's been able to
join the fray five minutes of cheats you
trying to push for that the leading edge
is getting
hi jack g2 Sean says you listen to that
crowd as SKT turn it around Ryan joins
the top side here they go Lord abyssal
voyage will deliver to the
[Applause]
carrot as the face G to obliterate SKT
look at all the death by mister look at
this staff their authority over to the
SK Telecom to speak and make their way
to the final Baron empowered minions are
pushing into the face the cat beat damn
Oh goats can't bleed where were you when
the West
[Music]
once again has to stare into his own
despair it's a well-deserved victory
petit Baker hadn't won MSI but worlds
was still on the table first though
they'd have to earn a spot
well now mr. Duncan guilt I was another
at home we played open in Tokyo if you
don't get wait and Sunday but SKT start
to lck summer 2019 was anything but
encouraging after winning their first
match they dropped five straight they
take the 2-0 victory over SK Telecom
well done Nippon our guys although the
street clearly had an impact on faker he
never seemed to lose confidence that
they could turn it around
[Music]
yeah Baker had predicted a perfect end
to the season they didn't quite get
there but lost only twice in the
remaining 11 matches it was classic SKT
they just had to make playoffs and they
would always be a contender
SK T's placement meant they had to run
the whole gauntlet and run it they did
and we'll be going here on fleek nice
knock but still this is an echo and you
know the party never ends if you're an
echo player and when they got to the
finals against Griffin he was clear that
SKT had come a long way
this wasn't a team of untested
youngsters following along and fakers
footsteps they were a force to be
reckoned with
[Applause]
just watch this is real he's looking for
it gets the flash here comes cod over
the turret going for the kill
what a bad sell out from his buddy petty
but he's able to do it alone or not
Griffin going for the berry here khaki
it's gonna be upset when he's gonna get
in there it goes to the Frog effort gets
it there and spikes it away a level 14
how is he able to do it this time it's
not played but it still escaped a and
the teamfight afterwards is done and
we've all seen this video before it's
like the recording con is gonna end the
game once again on the split-push we're
going to a 2-0 lead now to SKT griffey
go all-in and the cards are up on the
table SKT win against and how the health
bar in goes effort everybody and what a
way to hit the game has taken a sweet
ribbon here into the number and they are
going to do it this baby will sleep in
the playoffs and take down every single
team in their path they are the most
dominant team from the Korean region and
they are the very accurate winners of
today's
faker had once again displayed domestic
dominance but he couldn't rest as the
world's best gathered to battle for the
summoner's Cup despite every player
being individually strong the team
behind him had seemed ironclad at times
and out of sync at others if they wanted
to win worlds they would need to
consistency they had found only recently
and at the end of it all SKT emerged
first in their group topping EU second
seed fnatic and China second seed
orangey it was one of the toughest
worlds groups ever and their only loss
was to fnatic their quarterfinal match
was against Europe's third seed splice
who they defeated comfortably 3-1 the
battle became do they can look for a lot
of damage but already Thursday is gone
miss a shot to the back lines not going
to live either as Katy gods can bleed
but they will not die a quarterfinal win
three two one and
next week but their next opponent wasn't
just in their way for faker avenging
himself against g2 eSports was personal
g2 struck first but SKT managed even the
series and with the gold nearly even in
Game four the match ended with a
nail-biting teamfight that soft Baker
and SKT eliminated in dramatic fashion
it out though Clint had to go up into
the air it doesn't matter if he messed
it up because later still gonna go down
the pot went to the backside cap goes
Bolin there's no one else to follow up
cause David doesn't matter the altie
comes out a touch of closing shades for
now they're winning but first is coming
in this is his hero moment if he wants
to turn this fight in favor of team this
could be the game there's no way cooling
off so about us coming in business
walking into the meat grinder up hurts
come on can't do it
32 on can't get it done you can't the
Wladimir they can't do it this is that
[Music]
history of legal
taken down by the greatest team Europe
has ever produced
pH get
j2 is
to Paris
[Applause]
[Music]
as Europe celebrated Baker left the
stage quickly hardened by his
experiences in 2017 he tried to look at
the positive but one thing's for certain
Baker could have walked off that stage
in 2019 chose to retire right then and
there and he'd still be known as the
greatest of all time another token azure
window manager Choi a la dee da GU could
manage a product went further on in
terrible shape Alberto mangos a widow
he terminated in the off season faker
re-upped his contract with SKT now
rebranded to t1 gone now work on chlid
and Matta perhaps even more shocking was
the departure of their longtime coach
kkoma who had been an integral part of
the organization's long-term dominance
and who had coached faker since he was
first recruited from Korean soloqueue in
2013 their ad carry teddy remained as
did effort who had started over Matta
through most of worlds and filling the
spots left vacant for a variety of new
faces trainee Khanna and veteran Roach
were added to the top lane while cuz was
recruited to fill the jungle vacancy on
paper it's hard to say that this team
looks stronger than the one that
included Khan and [ __ ] the team finished
third fourth at the Kasbah Cup but has
had strong results in the lck so far as
for faker the truth is he doesn't need
to win in 2020 to be the greatest but
you can be certain that he'll be trying
his damndest no matter what and it won't
surprise anyone
if it happens because as long as faker
is in the game there's a chance that the
plausible can become inevitable and the
wounded can again become
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification fell for unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit up our Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]